voisins le bretonneux compte 11000 426
habitants en 2020 mais elle a perdu 1000
habitants en 15 ans malgré la production
de 590 logement ces dernières années à
voisins le bretonneux les projets
immobiliers se succèdent 29 logements
dans le centre 95 logements dans le
quartier du lac ou encore 110 logements
à la grande île des projets vont
également sortir de terre c'est le cas à
rue hélène boucher et 18 logements vont
voir le jour à prévoir pour 2022 sur ce
terrain vague la construction de
l'écoquartier la zone d'aménagement
concerté du quartier et de la remise
comptera 500 logements avec notamment un
parc arboré et des jardins partagés
voisins le bretonneux n'a que 18,5 % de
logements sociaux contre 25 % exigés par
l'état d'ici 2025
le point noir la circulation à voisins
le bretonneux lieu de transit entre la
vallée de chevreuse et saint quentin en
yvelines
les carrefours sont des points de
ralentissements en heure de pointe en
jeu également le nouveau cimetière le
projet de construction d'un troisième
cimetière à la place du square des 40
arpents a été contestée un collectif
s'est constitué pour s'opposer à sa
création
après ce mouvement de contestation deux
autres terrains potentiels sont à
l'étude ou en passe de l'être
enfin autre inquiétude pour les vies
sinois la moitié des médecins
généralistes partent bientôt à la
retraite et ne prennent pas de nouveaux
patients pour pallier cette pénurie les
habitants attendent une maison de santé
pluriprofessionnelle elle devrait être
construite à l'emplacement de l'ancien
leader price au centre de la grande île
des généralistes et spécialistes sont
recherchés